Trascrizione: Silvia Ruggiero
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Sono una psicologa
e una psicoterapeuta strategica,
e mi sono sempre
molto interessata alla felicità.
Si può dire che è stata
la motivazione della mia esistenza
e probabilmente la molla
per il mio lavoro.
Quando avevo 12 anni,
ho deciso che avrei fatto psicologia
e che l'avrei fatto
per aiutare le persone ad essere felici.
Pensavo: "Tutti vogliono essere felici."
Ebbene, dopo 20 anni di psicoterapia,
e 27.000 sedute,
ho scoperto molte cose:
intanto, che non è vero
che tutti vogliono essere felici;
e poi, che non tutti quelli
che dicono di voler essere felici
fanno davvero le cose giuste
per riuscirci.
E quindi servono
delle istruzioni, per riuscirci.
E, per la verità, la scienza
ce ne ha date tante, di istruzioni.
Perché della felicità si è occupata,
diciamo, da secoli,
la poesia, la filosofia,
la sociologia, la psicologia, le scienze.
Per esempio, sappiamo
molte cose sulla felicità.
Un contributo importante ce l'ha dato
"La psicologia positiva"
di Martin Seligman,
che è un'area della psicologia scientifica
che si occupa di capire
in che modo il pensiero positivo
influenza la nostra fisiologia,
la nostra psicologia,
e dunque il nostro benessere.
E sappiamo molte cose.
Sappiamo, per esempio,
che una gran parte della felicità
dipende da tre fattori,
tre fattori che hanno sulla nostra vita
un'incidenza diversa.
Per esempio, per il 50 percento
abbiamo un fattore che è quello
della felicità "costituzionale",
cioè quello che arriva in eredità
dalla nostra famiglia,
dalla nostra storia familiare.
E pesa al 50 percento
sulla nostra percezione di felicità.
Poi abbiamo un altro fattore
che incide per il dieci percento
sulla nostra felicità,
e che sono le circostanze della vita.
Per esempio, essere nati
in un paese ricco e democratico
è un elemento positivo
per la nostra felicità.
Poi abbiamo un altro fattore
che incide per il 40 percento,
e che quindi è molto importante,
e che è sotto il nostro controllo,
cioè è legato alle nostre scelte;
se riusciamo o meno a fare pace
con un passato che ci fa del male;
se riusciamo a costruire
relazioni positive
e a stare in contesti positivi;
se riusciamo a nutrire pensieri positivi,
se riusciamo ad essere ottimisti.
Per esempio, sappiamo che essere ottimisti
riduce i nostri rischi
di malattie cardiovascolari,
riduce la possibilità
di avere malattie infettive,
addirittura riduce il tasso di mortalità.
Eppure, nonostante sappiamo molte cose,
sappiamo addirittura cosa succede
dal punto di visto scientifico,
neuronale, ormonale nel nostro corpo
quando proviamo un'emozione positiva,
nonostante sappiamo tutte queste cose,
continuiamo a non essere felici.
Allora cosa serve per la felicità?
Evidentemente non basta la conoscenza:
la conoscenza è importante,
ma non è quella che trasforma le cose.
Quello che trasforma le cose
è qualcosa che attraversa
le nostre emozioni,
che ci passa in modo profondo dentro;
e che quindi ci cambia,
ci aiuta ad avere
una prospettiva differente.
E per farlo, naturalmente,
dobbiamo avere un'idea
di che cosa vogliamo,
ognuno di noi, per essere felici.
Perché la prima domanda
che dobbiamo farci è:
"Che cosa mi serve,
in questo momento della mia vita,
per sentirmi veramente felice?"
La felicità non è uno stato permanente,
non è una dimensione statica.
È qualcosa di fuggevole, sfuggente,
come lo sono tutte le emozioni.
Quindi abbiamo bisogno di capire
che cosa serve a noi,
e anche in che modo ci sentiamo
veramente bene con noi stessi.
L'idea che essere ricchi e famosi
renda felici tutti
è una fantasia, un'illusione.
Ognuno di noi ha la propria felicità,
e ha la propria felicità di quel momento.
Quindi dovrebbe chiedersi,
in quel momento, che cosa gli serve,
perché deve imparare anche a realizzare
che le cose che un tempo
lo rendevano felice
non necessariamente lo renderanno
felice in quel momento
né tanto meno lo renderanno felice domani.
O che le cose che rendono felice lui,
non necessariamente renderanno felice
qualcun altro, ma soltanto lui.
Dunque è un compito
che spetta ad ognuno di noi.
Ma per farlo dobbiamo,
innanzitutto, crederci.
Dunque dobbiamo sapere
che la felicità è, anche,
un principio, una regola,
una motivazione, una prospettiva.
In sostanza,
dobbiamo poter credere nella felicità,
per sentire la felicità.
Non basta desiderarla
perché questa avvenga magicamente.
Ma ci sono anche molte cose
che ci ostacolano
nel raggiungere la felicità:
per esempio, molte paure.
Una paura che assilla gli esseri umani
è, per esempio, quella di deludere
le aspettative degli altri.
Oppure, un'altra importante paura
che ci ostacola pesantemente
è la paura del giudizio degli altri,
di avere un giudizio negativo
da parte degli altri.
Oppure, ancora, la difficoltà
di appartenere ad una minoranza,
perché se saremo felici
saremo sempre meno
di quelli che sono infelici.
Quindi abbiamo bisogno, eventualmente,
di un elemento che ci aiuti
a superare questi ostacoli
e ad andare incontro alla felicità.
E questo elemento è il coraggio.
Voi mi direte: "È un paradosso.
Che coraggio ci vuole ad essere felici?
Che ci vorrà mai?"
E poi: "Che tipo di coraggio serve,
per essere felici?"
Io non vi risponderò con una definizione,
per tutto quello che vi ho detto prima;
ma voglio fare con voi un piccolo viaggio,
voglio farlo attraverso una storia,
così da rappresentarci
il senso del coraggio
di cui parliamo stasera.
C'è un tizio, guardate
che bella faccia allegra che ha.
Un tizio, una persona che ha una famiglia,
un lavoro, degli interessi,
e una passione: ama i safari.
Sapete quelli di caccia grossa, in Africa.
Ed è proprio in un safari,
con il suo gruppo,
che durante una pausa è rapito
da uno scorcio meraviglioso
di un tramonto africano.
Si allontana dal suo gruppo,
si allontana dal suo autobus,
dove sono montati i fucili, le munizioni,
dove sono i suoi compagni,
e si va a godere
questo scorcio di tramonto
accanto a quest'albero maestoso,
con gli occhi persi nell'arancione
e nel rosso dell'Africa.
A un certo punto, sente una presenza:
si volta, e di fronte si trova un leone.
È disarmato, è atterrito.
Con la coda dell'occhio guarda i compagni,
che hanno visto la scena
e che stanno cercando di scaricare
le munizioni, i fucili
per aiutare il compagno.
Lui no, non ama questo.
Non vuole essere visto come un debole,
non vuole essere visto come vulnerabile,
non vuole l'aiuto degli altri.
E quindi, fa come se di fronte
non avesse un leone,
come se quelle non fossero zanne e fauci,
e convinto cammina
per andare verso i suoi compagni.
E, risultato della storia,
finisce sbranato.
Okay, riavvolgiamo indietro il nastro.
Stesso tizio, stessa passione,
stesso safari, stesso tramonto -
ahi ahi ahi, stesso leone.
È lì, è di fronte al leone,
è atterrito, è disarmato,
è terrorizzato.
Con la coda dell'occhio, guarda gli amici.
Gli amici stanno scaricando
i fucili, le munizioni.
vogliono aiutarlo,
avrebbero potuto trovarsi
nella stessa situazione.
Lui si rende immobile:
quasi non respira
per non muovere un muscolo.
Le gambe gli tremano come foglie,
e lui cerca di controllarle.
Davanti ai suoi occhi
gli passa tutta la sua vita:
i progetti che ha realizzato,
quelli che invece vuole ancora realizzare,
le persone che ama,
le persone che ha perso - tutto.
Si sente perduto
quando, all'improvviso,
sente un fragore e un tonfo.
I suoi compagni hanno puntato
e abbattuto il leone.
Lui è salvo, e può continuare
a godersi il suo safari.
Ora io vi chiedo:
"Chi è, per voi, quello coraggioso?
Cos'è il coraggio?"
Qualcuno mi dirà
che il coraggio è quello del primo tizio,
e quindi l'idea che ha del coraggio
è di una invulnerabilità.
Il coraggio come assenza di paura;
il coraggio come potenza assoluta;
il coraggio come chi non accetta
di avere dei limiti, affanni, cadute;
il coraggio come chi crede
di non aver bisogno
dell'aiuto di nessuno, mai.
E come finisce la storia?
Non bene.
Poi c'è il secondo tizio.
Che tipo di coraggio mette in atto lui?
È un coraggio diverso.
È il coraggio di chi accetta i limiti,
di chi può tollerare l'impotenza,
di chi ha la forza di resistere,
di chi crede nella possibilità
di avere una chance,
di chi accetta l'aiuto degli altri,
quando non può fare diversamente;
e resiste.
E come finisce la storia?
Si salva,
e avrà molte altre opportunità
di essere felice.
Dunque con questo che cosa ci diciamo?
Diciamo che il coraggio di essere felici
presuppone l'idea
che la felicità non sia soltanto
cose belle che accadono da sole,
ma sia la capacità
di superare le difficoltà,
di affrontare le cadute,
di accettare anche le proprie fragilità.
E di andare in contro
in modo ottimistico, positivo
e superare i problemi,
e affrontare i problemi.
In fondo, la felicità è la capacità
di godersi la fatica
nel trovare una soluzione.
Non soltanto la soluzione,
ma tutto il percorso, tutto il viaggio.
Non "non avere alcun problema",
perché questo non è realistico.
La felicità è tutto il processo,
il problema e la soluzione.
La felicità non è un eden.
La felicità è la capacità
di godersi tutto lo sforzo
e di pensare che,
al di là di quella difficoltà,
c'è un momento meraviglioso per me.
Nella nostra vita abbiamo
continuamente leoni da affrontare,
abbiamo prove importanti
a cui dare delle risposte,
da cui possiamo fuggire,
o che possiamo avere il coraggio,
invece, di reagire, di affrontare.
Il tipo di lavoro da scegliere,
l'uomo con cui passeremo
il resto della nostra vita.
Sulla base di che tipo di coraggio
noi facciamo queste scelte?
La felicità dev'essere il clima
che diamo alla nostra esistenza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)